i've got a really charming problem to
explain to you today and before i start
on my solution and my proof i want to
preface this by saying it's the kind of
question that i don't spend a lot of
time doing by which i mean it doesn't
connect to a particular topic that i
often teach which means that the
solution i'm about to show you i don't
think is especially elegant and i i know
that like i bet there is some technique
out there that's kind of like oh this is
very obvious here's the way to do it
it's very straightforward and succinct
and brief
however i have not thought of that
solution so i'm going to show you the
way that i thought about this
nonetheless and i'm going to try and do
my best to explain it in simple terms i
could do it in very technical terms but
there's a good chance a lot of the
people who are watching this uh will
will not really be able to follow that
proof so i want to make sure that
a broad range of people will be able to
comprehend uh how it is that i've gone
about thinking about this problem and
maybe you know off the back of my
thinking maybe that would be enough of a
hint or a prompt that you can come up
with your own solution or if you come up
with a more uh elegant way of solving
and proving this then i would love to
hear about it you can post it in the
comments or something like that so
let's have a look at the problem
together it says
how many solutions are there for the
equation
x to the y plus y minus x equals y to
the x on the condition that x and y are
positive and prime numbers there you go
those are the conditions
how do we go about solving this well my
first instinct when i had a look at this
was to say it is weird especially when
you're dealing with this x and y
business it makes you think oh is this
an equation where i'm supposed to graph
something
am i looking for a point of intersection
between two curves because normally when
you have one thing equal to another
that's often the way that you can think
about it
now we will get to that kind of thinking
later on but this question actually is
sort of couched in terms that make us
think in terms of like number theory uh
number theory being that topic where
we're dealing with whole numbers um all
prime numbers are whole and saying it's
positive is a it's slightly redundant
but uh it's probably good just to make
sure it's it's rigorous that we include
that condition there as well
now what i'm going to do is sort of walk
you through my thinking process so i'm
not just going to straight away show you
an answer but i'm going to try and give
you insight into my brain in the way i
thought this through okay now my first
uh sort of instinct was to take this
equation that uh the question hands to
us and to say well okay if i just take
this and do a fairly straightforward
manipulation to it
you can
reframe or restate this equation in a
way that allows you to see a fairly
crucial insight about this equation
which is if i take that uh that term
right there that minus x if i add x to
both sides have a look at what we get
i'm going to write that x to the y plus
y
remaining on the left hand side and then
on the right hand side i get y to the x
and then here comes the plus x which i
just added to both sides now
what's going on here what difference
does it make that i've put this over
here on the right hand side of the
equation
stare closely at this equation and i
wonder if you notice it has any
interesting properties maybe if i say it
aloud you might see it more clearly x to
the y plus y
equals y to the x plus x
do you see that this equation as written
and much more than how it was in its
original form this equation is
marvelously symmetrical there is a kind
of symmetry and matching and
correspondence between the left-hand
side and the right-hand side of the
equation if i were for example
to take the x's on the left-hand side
which is only one
and the y's actually maybe i'll just use
a different color there with the y's
on the left hand side and if i were to
swap them put y's everywhere i see x's
and x's everywhere that i see y's you
can see what's going to happen can't you
right the y's are going to become like
these x's here
on the
right hand side
and this x in here is going to become
like this y
on the right hand side so by switching
the variables around by swapping them
you can transfer back and forth between
the left and the right hand side now
what that means is and again looking at
the conditions that we've been provided
here
one answer to this question how many
solutions are there for the equation
immediately is well there must be
infinitely many because if x and y are
kind of symmetrical like this then if x
and y happen to be equal to each other
right if i say you know
if
y equals x then the left hand side is
going to be well every y i'll replace it
with an x so you get x to the x plus
x and the right hand side if i do the
same thing there's only a single y there
if i swap it with an x you get x to the
x plus x which means that
because there is an infinite number of
prime numbers thank you euclid for
proving that in a wonderfully elegant
way uh
so long as y and x are the same prime
number like three or five or uh 7 and so
on and so on
this left hand side and right hand side
are going to obviously be equal to each
other because you're getting the same
result
now mathematicians often call an answer
like this kind of like a trivial
solution it's like yeah it's true
but who cares it's not interesting it
doesn't give us any insight into what
this equation is like the original
question
it doesn't help us particularly
understand anything profound so even
though it may be true it's not
especially useful and so we often kind
of disregard it right so if we were to
add an additional condition which is not
just you know how many solutions are
there for the equation i've just
established if you don't mind x and y
being the same number which happens all
the time
then there's an infinite number so i can
put that to one side
what if i add the condition that x and y
have to be not just positive and prime
but distinct what if they have to be
separate to each other and unequal this
becomes a little more interesting now
right given this additional restriction
on what x and y and can be
well this trivial solution is gone i
have to abandon it because i'm saying
well this this thing here you're not
allowed to do that so how will i go
about solving this now
um at this next point i thought okay
well how do i try and get a handle on on
how this equation works and what i did
was i started with something uh fairly
low low level that like it didn't take
much cognitive effort or thinking or
intelligence which was i just started
throwing numbers at this equation now
x and y are positive and prime now if
i'm again saying well they have to be
different
the first two prime numbers are 2 and 3.
and interestingly if we say i mean
because of the symmetry it doesn't
matter if x is 2 and y is 3 or the other
way around if i made y 2 and x equal to
3
an interesting thing happens when you
just put in these first two prime
numbers let's just
suppose x equals 2 and y equals 3. what
do we get on the left-hand side well
let's go ahead i'm going to get
2 cubed plus 3.
2 cubed is 8 add 3 and you get 11. then
when you try out the right hand side
we're switching everything around so
it's going to be 3 squared plus
2 that's 9 plus 2 which again is equal
to
11. so i've got a solution now right
woohoo
i've matched the left and the right hand
side so x equals 2 y equals 3 or again i
think we would treat it as the same
solution if you were to swap
around your x and y values there
it works right